[Music]
this is the ramsey
show you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice doing this show now almost 30
years and
getting to um
meet some of my heroes along the way has
been one of my great joys and then
occasionally actually getting to become
friends with them and even more than
that getting to do some work with them
from time to time today is no exception
for that pastor louis giglio of passion
church in atlanta uh good friend has
stopped by with his new book and we're
so honored to have you with us here my
friend i couldn't be happier to be here
with you congrats on the space it's
absolutely stunning well thank you thank
you you know you know about spaces with
passion and the passion movement and uh
fabulous books over the years if you've
never heard pastor louis giglio speak i
don't know where you've been he's one of
the top communicators in the world and
uh you if you're in the atlanta area
always or anywhere you can catch him
passion city church i've had the
privilege of speaking there and just
wonderful people wonderful family of god
good good folks and i always like
getting to hang out with him especially
when we get to talk about a new book
that he's doing called don't give the
enemy a seat at your table that's pretty
straight on it's really to the point
it's one of those books that you don't
have to read the whole book i do
recommend that people read the book
but i like the ones that you get the
message on the cover total money
makeover total money makeover that's
what i need to do oh you're going to
tell me how to do that this is the
message don't give the enemy a seat at
your table if this enemy could come into
paradise dave think about it paradise
and lie his way in
to the hearts of mankind and say good
god isn't good
and you can't trust him
if he can do that in paradise he can
definitely do it in my life he could do
it in anybody's life he could do it in
atlanta he could do it in nashville he
can do he can do it in dallas and
houston he can do it when things are
unraveling and it's not paradise
if he could do it in paradise so we got
to watch what we think we got to be
careful what thought we allow to take a
seat at our table you know
this is apparently my week for spiritual
warfare um books and information are the
pastor that did our devotional yesterday
was from kansas city spoke on uh the
subject of of that and has just written
a book on it as well that i've read half
of it this morning before i came to work
and um
but but uh
you know he was
just making the point that that
and you know this more than i do but i
also already knew it but i was good to
be reminded that very seldom does the
enemy uh
come straight at you instead he brings
you something that's 98 percent truth
yeah i mean there's there's a very few
occasions where the enemy shows up and
says hey i'm the enemy uh i would like
to rip your eyeballs out yeah you know
i want to destroy your marriage i would
like to destroy your confidence i want
to take your business down now he comes
in that side door where where i was
actually when i got this message i'd
been to about a four-month battle
and some things have been said some
things have been done about four months
in i get a phone call and the phone call
is i bet you've got one like this you're
not going to believe what happened today
it was that moment of vindication
and i reached out to a friend and i and
i said you are not going to believe what
i just heard if you give things enough
time
what did i want dave i wanted
commiseration i want somebody just to
come alongside and say hey man you're
good and you were right
but my friend knew i didn't need
commiseration my friend that i sent the
text to knew that i needed a wake-up
call because i was acting like an orphan
when i'm the son of a king
and he sent me nine words in reply don't
give the enemy a seat at your table in
other words his whole four months of
consternation frustration
all this internal processing you've been
doing all that is because you let the
enemy sit at your table and you need to
take your thinking back starting today
and that text became the cover of this
book the title of this book and that
text has literally changed my life over
the last six eight years well when you
get pounded and uh i have been this year
you have been this year a lot of people
have been this year by different things
um
uh but i mean i watched and and sent you
positive texts during that time as well
and
uh uh
you know i we forget
to do the basics like take every thought
captive and instead we sit and it's
almost like in the seventh grade at the
lunch table you know when you walk away
and you go you know now i know what i
should have said now and you just play
these tapes over and over and over and
over and over again about how you're
going to hit back or how you're not
going to hit back or how you're going to
do this all that and all of that is just
you're playing right into this yeah
that's what i'm saying you know it's uh
we want to control
everyone if they really are honest wants
to control and we don't control a lot
like this global craziness that we're
living in no one's in control of that
so what are we in control of we're in
control of the truth that god has given
us for our lives and
i think that you know when
when we get in a moment like that what
we normally do is just say okay great
fear you're at the table worry you're at
the table anger you're at the table
instead of going wait a minute where did
you come from
and that's what this book talks about
asking the thought
where did you come from
and if that thought doesn't line up with
the character the purposes the heart and
the word of god
then it didn't come from god right and
if it didn't come from god it doesn't
get a seat at the table and so you got
to know the truth because you don't win
this battle by fighting against a lie
you win this battle by embracing the
truth you know that's convicting and
disgusting at the same time because i
did i just i completely violated that
and i'm not like an immature person i'm
like an immature person spiritually or
emotionally anything else and i
completely violated that i can look back
in the last nine months and go i did
that there i did that there i did that
and i know better
well this is a good reminder yeah we all
know better and i think the thing that
what i would want to encourage people in
and for me
is that you don't win the battle of your
mind one time you win the battle of your
mind every day that's what god's word
says renew your mind every single day
keep renewing your mind to the truth and
it's not something that you do and then
walk away from because uh our minds are
an open field to whatever seeds want to
get blown there by whatever wind is
coming our way and we've got to think
every single time
i've got
the authority to take control of my mind
and then that what people really need to
start with i can do this i can change
the way i think
yeah i'm
i'm in charge of my thoughts uh no one
else is it's one of the few things i
actually can control
do not don't give the enemy a seat at
your table it's for sale anywhere great
books are for sale pastor louis giglio
of passion city church the original
visionary of the entire passion movement
is my guest this segment and this is a
book we all need as a reminder because
not only do you become who you hang
around with you become what you think
about
and uh both of those are scriptural
concepts and uh and if you hang around
with and think about the enemies
processes thoughts and presence you're
going to get a lot out of him pastor
love you love you too so good to see you
appreciate you coming by and hanging out
with us here in nashville again the book
don't give the enemy a seat
at your table
this is the ramsey shack
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
number one best-selling author ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we take your questions about
your life and your money here on the
ramsey show open phones at triple eight
eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
825-5225
[Music]
well happy birthday ken well thank you
dave
i uh
it's it's hard to believe they sneak up
on me every year i don't know if yours
do but mine do
kind of like i didn't see it coming i
got all the old man jokes right so it's
like uh the closer it's like life's like
toilet paper the closer you get to the
end the faster it goes oh it's it's so
good dave we got this fun tradition i
got to let people in on this where dave
sends out everybody gets an email if
you're ramsey solutions teammate you get
an email on your birthday and there's
always some fun
uh gif or whatever they call it jiff or
gif i never know what to say
and today was a picture of albert
einstein
saying that uh studies show that uh
birthdays are good things you know
something something along those lines
studies show that birthdays are good for
statistics birthdays are good for you
the more of them you have the longer you
live that's right so today is a day of
gratitude another year in the books
47 dave
really yeah
well i wouldn't have thunk it really
yeah i would have thought you're much
older than that
boy
folks that's what's called being reeled
in i just
he had me with the hook and i thought i
was gonna bless me with like 41 or
something
yeah so what is this this is your 30 or
your 28th anniversary of your 29th
birthday yeah not bad it's hard to
believe not bad there we go
good stuff the maturity doesn't match
the age as we know we're still working
on that i'm in heaven listen if you're
mature you're no good in talk radio so
let me just help you with that yeah
phone number triple eight eight two five
five two two five cali is gonna start us
off in indianapolis hi callie how are
you
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so i'm getting married at the end of
august i'm super excited to marry this
man and we've talked about our deaths
from premarital counseling i do have a
medical debt for my son that was about
47 000. he was in the pq for a couple
weeks and
i didn't have insurance unfortunately at
the time i do now so that's taken care
of but i was curious where i put
my medical debt that's actually now in
collections because it started around
covid time so i couldn't pay it where
would i put that in the baby steps once
we go through financial peace whenever
we get signed up for that where would i
end up putting my son's medical debt
within our other debt so what do you
make
i make 57. what about him
he makes 85. and when you're getting
married
august 29th congratulations
thank you how's your baby doing
uh he's doing so much better he is the
light of my life and the light of my
fiancee's life he's a lot better now
it's a sleek incident he aspirated a
peanut
so you just uh um
you just outlined a life that is going
really really well and we get to work on
and all we have to work on is some math
stuff so really good yeah you're in a
good place very nice and how much debt
do you have not counting this
i have so we have a car i have a car
that's 7 000 that's our smallest debt
and then i would pay all together i
think we have about
eighty thousand
counting the forty seven or not
not counting the forty seven what's the
rest of the eighty student loans
he has fewer loans yeah he's a gm
a hotel
and then i have my car and then i also
so during coven i didn't have insurance
and that doesn't help so i ended up
crashing my car and i'm paying them
twelve thousand for that
okay so but the biggest number on this
is student loans
the biggest number is just seeing them
get there okay
all right now is the uh
if
are are they attempting to collect are
you paying any payments on the 47.
i'm not paying any payments right now
his son was supposed to help me that's
our his father was supposed to help me
that's actually in our mediation
agreement that hasn't happened yet
um but i was paying payments and then i
stopped and so it's gone to collections
i called about it and it's at a
collection a collection agency okay
right now but they're not calling on it
no yeah um here's the thing you probably
can settle this for
say 50 cents on the dollar something
like that if you had the lump sum
and so i would take something like a
number like a 20 000 number and plug
that into your debt snowball wherever it
really goes it sounds like it's before
the student loans but after some of the
car stuff
and i'd build up 20 000 cash and i would
call them is this is this a single bill
or a total of 47 on medical
it's a single bill it's at a children's
hospital yeah i would also call the
hospital administrator and see if you
can get an in-person meeting with covet
i doubt you can but anytime you can meet
with someone in person you can plead
your case better and just go you know i
don't have any money obviously the
reason i didn't have i didn't have i
don't have a insurance reason i have an
insurance i didn't have any money so if
you guys will settle this we we
appreciate the
uh we appreciate the service you gave us
we're thankful for that and uh we don't
want to be anything but but honorable
but we just don't have forty seven
thousand dollars if you guys will take
twenty thousand i'll get it to you
really really fast and then make it a
priority if you can get a settlement
agreement but any settlements you do you
do in writing
and uh and and you never give a
collector of any kind electronic access
to your checking account because they
lie
it's a problem yeah
dave what happens if she goes to the
hospital and i love that advice
the hospital has an option there to call
the collection agency i presume and say
hey we want to pull this back we've
talked to them and we're working this
out yeah they can they don't usually if
you just call them yeah that's why but
an in-person meeting where you go in not
accusing the hospital of having done
something wrong that's right like why do
you people charge so much you know none
of that and you're the price problem
with you no no you this is a children's
hospital to help you with your child
you're grateful yeah
and uh yeah you start with that and then
you go well you know it's just a math
problem it's not a matter of intent i
don't have the money and if you guys
will settle this we can get it knocked
out pretty fast if we're going to pay
the whole 47 it's going to take a long
time yep
and you most of the time it's
interesting
even people in the administration
in hospitals
hospitals tend to attract people with
mercy
yes
merciful people yes and so not always
but they have a tendency to do that they
move into the medical field for one
reason or another and so you you
oftentimes find someone with heart
but again you're not going in
belligerent no you're not going in
accusing them of having done something
wrong if you're going to do that you
need an attorney yes uh but that's you
know because the hospital somehow
malpractice or something like that but
that's not what we're hearing here no in
fact i was gonna say if you have the
spirit that you have on this call yeah
this is a woman who sees the end she's
gonna knock it out she's excited about
the days ahead and you know part of this
deal is you got a deadbeat dude on the
other side of this isn't helping i'd
share that story too and go hey but i'm
not relying on him i'm here to handle
this you help my baby and i want to do
the right thing i think that conviction
along with the spirit she has is very
attractive it is i mean it's just human
nature and it's proper relationships and
but sometimes what happens is we get
afraid
um or we are ashamed and out of those
emotions
we we project something else rather than
humility we project anger
uh some of the meanest people in the
world are people that are afraid yes you
know as an example so uh
you that's not her no and so you know i
think you knock out your car then you
knock out the car debt where you uh hit
somebody else without insurance and then
you put twenty thousand dollars on the
list and then you get to the student
loans and you guys just attack that as
fast as you can any money you get from
the ex uh the dad of the child this
would be called gravy on the biscuit
because it's unexpected
and and you'll get there as fast as you
can now i think we can go a little step
further and say
uh if you have if you're out there and
you let's just kind of do a teaching
segment if you have a bunch of
debts in collection that you haven't
paid on it's been 10 months 20 months
since you paid on this credit card
it's been 10 months 20 months since you
paid on this uh old bad debt from
whatever uh from a medical bill or
whatever else uh you make a different
list of those things
when you're working your debt snowball
if you got a whole bunch of that and
this is one singular debt
and it had an unusual story around it
but you'd make you'd knock out your
existing debt snowball first
the ones you're current on because that
frees up all those payments you don't
have anymore and then you work through
the defaulted
student loan or the defaulted debt
snowball one
debt at a time
settle it close it in writing no
electronic access to your checking
account do the next one do the next one
do the next one but freeing up those
doesn't free up cash flow because you're
not paying payments on
this is the ramsey shack
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage ken fonnie joins us from
jacksonville florida hey bonnie how are
you hi dave
i'm good how are you good to have you
i'm excited to be here all the way from
jacksonville very cool all the way from
florida how much have you paid off
about forty three thousand dollars love
it how long did that take almost 14
months good and your range of income
during that time i started at about 81
and then just got another promotion so
i'm at about
five hey hey i like it i like it what do
you do for a living i'm a service
executive for a technology company so
client relations essentially yeah good
good and obviously good at it very good
thank you so what kind of debt was your
forty three thousand
a tax bill six credit cards a personal
loan from my parents
um that was pretty much it no student
loan debt okay
all right how old are you
i am 41 41 yeah and 14 months ago
you kind of have been bopping along with
this
like lower back pain
kind of debt that's what that kind of
debt is isn't it it's like it's you're
making enough that it's small enough
that you can almost ignore it if you
take a few advil you know but but it's
but it just keeps coming back and it's
always there is that right yes it was
what happened what broke you lose
um i was planning a
extravagant birthday trip to south
africa for my 40th birthday yum yeah um
a trip i couldn't afford and i was
taking stock of my life and how to come
to do this moment with myself
oh it's the old 40th birthday 40th
birthday thing yeah so
um taking a look at my finances and
knowing i couldn't afford it and then i
was in a toxic relationship at the time
i didn't like my job basically i wanted
to change everything
and was looking for ways to cut costs so
i
enlisted the help of my parents and
asked if i could move in with them for a
year wow to pay off yeah so they're and
they were one of the debts and so they
said yes yes
i paid them first
and
it was a huge blessing because then
covet came along and so we let the
boyfriend go first and asked him to
leave and then i got a different job
that i liked a lot more
and good job no boyfriend no apartment
lease no trip to south africa and we're
getting out of debt right and look at
you
yes thank you it's been a long a long
journey sounds cleansing
it was very in more ways than financial
oh yeah career boyfriend the whole thing
i mean it's awesome this is great yeah
i'm very very grateful yeah i want to
ask you a quick progression there so you
gave us the range of income from 81 to
97. yeah so when you were in this
miserable job and you changed to
something you like is that where we pick
up 81 did you get a bump there or was it
a parallel move i actually went from 81
my first promotion was to about 87 okay
um and then the month after i was debt
free i got another promotion to 97.5 wow
and i feel like god was just saying
thank you for being a good steward of
what you have and now you don't have to
struggle as much anymore a little tip of
the hat from the holy spirit yeah
how much did the
loving the work really enjoy in the work
how much did that play into the any
mindset or emotion and performance that
led to what you believe did it lead to
the promotion is my question do you
think i think i was just hyper focused
so everything else that was positive
that i was drawing to myself i think
just led to a job promotion
it was more so my boss i didn't like
if i'm telling the truth um
that's not a surprise people leave
leaders not companies right yeah the
work was okay um i'm actually at the
same company i'm just
um have jumped apartments so good for
you yeah so much better not surprising
dave you hear that all the time yeah
focus yep focus to get out of debt led
to professional
gains not just
well and another thing was you cleaned
all this
junk out of your life and you were in
the process of clean junk out of your
life i did yeah of different kinds and
that that just this is such a great
story i'm so proud of you thank you your
parents got to be proud of you i hope so
they're here with me they came with you
to cheer right yes they did and my niece
kristabel as well all right very good
very good well that's cool that makes a
nice nashville trip not south africa but
a good time not south africa i told my
parents when this was all over i would
buy them a vacation so i'm sending them
on a cruise for their 50th wedding
anniversary this year that's awesome hey
that's more fun than going yourself
yes i'm very excited that's awesome very
cool
so 14 months 43 000 that's pretty
intense
yeah it was what do you tell people the
key is
living on a budget for sure um
for a while i did dave ish i took
financial piece years ago
um but like you said i had enough to
manage the chaos it was just sort of my
juggling system and now it's more of a
this is why i have hope and
focusing on investing and planning my
future and when i decided to do this i
was just in a really hopeless place and
struggling with depression and going
through a breakup so i was a hot mess
when i moved into my parents house
but i just i had a lot of shame um
dealing with thoughts that i hadn't been
a good steward of what god had given me
and i know i was capable of more
so i just prayed that
you know i could be the person i wanted
to be i wanted to be someone my family
would be proud of
and that one day i'd stand here they are
that's all they are they are proud of
you and we are too
and that shame flipped to conviction
then and it's game on yeah
yeah shame is destructive conviction to
get your button gear yeah
yeah well
i'm so proud of you well done very
powerful
well what i you know your whole life has
changed and it's the
that piece is just part of it it was
just part of it part of it but it almost
precipitated it in a sense it started
the whole ballroom it did it did i feel
like it really came to a head and
i was unrecognizable to myself and that
really started my journey
to be gonzalo tents and get out of debt
and change everything
but yeah i'm happier now than i've ever
been it's the highest base salary i've
ever had i just feel like
it's a reward for being a good steward
of and given you're free yes and you're
generally and you're and you're generous
yes and you're in a much healthier place
all the way around much of the area so
when the emotion just grabbed you
there
because you you were talking about i i
envisioned getting to this moment here
you are you did it you are standing on
the debt-free stage i want you to tell
people because the emotions still all
over you it was hard
is it worth it standing there moments
before you do your scream was it worth
it absolutely absolutely i would say for
anyone listening that's struggling
you know it's hard to hold on your hope
especially day after day like even in
the 40
you know plus thousand dollars i also
paid cash for about thirty 3 500 of car
repairs in that time
so anytime something would go wrong with
my car i was so discouraged and
you know i had a plan for i will beat up
free on this day and then something else
would go wrong
and i listened to your podcast and i
would hear the debt free screams and
just think you know if i just keep going
just one one more day i you know i can
do this
and um
and then the chains start to drop off
and you see the light at the end of the
tunnel it's not an oncoming train and
um here i am you are there i'm here
i'm just going to leave and let her do
the next segment yeah she could take
over the rest of the hour i'm just uh i
think everybody's signing up for
financial peace university right now
this is i'm amazed this is so powerful
well done very very well done
all right bonnie we've got a copy of the
legacy journey for you because that for
sure is your next chapter in your story
the chapter of generosity and legacy and
control and destiny and that's where
you're headed you're you're you're a
powerhouse you're amazing thank you you
grabbed every part of your life up by
the neck and shook it and made it behave
and it was very very powerful good it's
an honor to meet you
and also a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away because
you haven't shut up talking about this
and somebody that you know needs a copy
of it that you've been bothering about
this stuff
and uh
we're just so proud of you and i know
your mom and dad are very very well done
all right it's bonnie from jacksonville
florida 43
000
paid off in 14 months making 81 to 97.
what a great story count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two
debt-free
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
absolutely fabulous
unbelievable what a great story
this
is the ramsey shadow
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five you guys jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money if
you're in debt we know it can feel like
you're fighting a losing battle with
those bills sometimes you can feel stuck
like bonnie in our last debt-free scream
there you may wonder if you're ever
going to get ahead well you can you can
get control you can grab things by the
neck like she did you can build the life
you want we will show you how in
financial peace university
millions and millions and millions of
people have learned the proven plan
to work out of debt and into wealth
in financial peace university and of
course you're gonna be sticking to a
budget that's part of the plan and
you'll have the premium version of our
budgeting tool every dollar
both entree lead our both of every
dollar and financial peace university
are available at ramsey plus you can
start a free trial of ramsey plus and
end this constant battle
with and for your money just text trial
to 33 789 text trial two three three
seven
eight nine sarah is with us in los
angeles hi sarah welcome to the
well
ramsey
dave how are you better than i deserve
what's up
uh my husband and i are on baby step two
we've paid off twenty three thousand
dollars and have another twenty two to
go cool my mom keeps asking me to help
her and my dad figure out their budget
help them start on the ramsay plan i
just finished reading the total money
makeover and i gave her my copy good um
and now it's leading to us fighting
my
dad is 57 and my mom's 54. my dad wants
to retire soon they keep trying to
convince me that their 800 credit score
is good
my dad doesn't want to stop the 15 that
he's currently investing
um even though they're just shy of 110
000 in debt yeah well there's no reason
to find
that's what i say
do what
i said that's what i say yeah well so i
mean
if they don't want to do it they don't
have to do it
well
that's what i keep saying i'm not going
to fight over it it's because you guys
do whatever you want to do
you ask me so i told you what we were
doing i gave you a copy of the book but
you don't have to do it it's not a law
well that's what i'm trying to say and
then they turn around and they're like
oh well but we need to get out of debt
and we want to retire yeah but i mean i
showed you how you got you you gotta
decide which one you wanna do you can't
be both
if you wanna know how i did it i showed
you how i did it i used the total money
makeover baby steps this is how i did it
i don't know how to tell you how to do
it other than that that's the only way i
know this is you talking okay
and so and i'm not gonna fight with you
you guys can either do it or not do it
i'm gonna love you either way you're my
mom and dad
i'm going to love you even if you're
stupid
don't say don't say that but you can
think that yeah right no they'll kill me
i can't say that i know i know but you
see what i'm saying that's what's going
through your head right
but here's the thing the fight the fight
comes when
they are trying to convince you to not
do it
the ramsay stuff the baby steps and the
fight comes when you are trying to
convince them to do the baby steps
so the best way you can convince them is
to continue to do it properly yourself
and win and they'll con and sets an
example for them but you can't make
people do stuff
yeah
that's true you make little kids do
stuff but you can't make grown people do
stuff and you can only make your kids do
stuff
you can only make little kids do stuff
until you leave the room
that's right sarah one of the things
sarah i hear the tension for you because
they keep asking you and you're so
passionate you're so convicted on this
journey that you can't just answer a
question
you know and i think that that's where
there may be some tension there and i
think dave's absolutely right i think if
they keep asking a question you go uh
i'm not sure i'll text you later tonight
i think it's on page 87 of chapter 3 or
whatever and just stay out of the
communication if you're feeling your
tension rise uh because of your
tremendous conviction then you're gonna
have to just when they ask a question
say i'll look it up it's in this chapter
it's in chapter five or it's in chapter
six or whatever it is and give them the
answer but don't get involved in the
back and forth opinion stuff because
dave's right i don't want to do that
okay yeah great sure that's cool i don't
want i don't want to stop putting money
in my 401k okay
i mean i you know i if somebody calls me
up on the air here
and i'm the guy okay it's not just like
a theory for me this is i'm the guy that
wrote it and did it for me and tens of
millions of people right if somebody
calls me up here on the air and wants to
argue with me i'll talk to him for a
minute or two and then i just go to the
next caller
i'm not going to have a debate with
somebody about this because i'm right
i'm not going to have a discussion about
it i mean i'm not right about everything
but this stuff i mean 20 million people
have done this stuff under my direction
so it's not like it's wrong anymore you
know it's not it's not like an opinion
it's not a theory by a broke college
professor this is this is we do this and
this is i may not be able to do anything
else but this i can do so i'm not going
to argue with you about it if you don't
agree with me you're just what's known
as wrong and america is a great place
you're allowed to be wrong yeah and so
you know you just have to be kind about
it and have a little bit of that in your
head a little bit those kinds of tapes
almost sarcasm playing in your head and
you just kind of
don't be mean and don't be unkind and
just go dad if you don't want to do that
that's okay i understand i love you this
is what plan i'm doing
you are a grown man you get to choose
what you're going to do
and i'm going to love you either way
yeah and that creates the emotional
boundary that you need you need that you
need to be able to put a boundary out
there and go we're doing it we're all in
for us mom and dad they got their big
boy pants on and their big girl pants so
at some point uh don't get sucked into
the back and forth on it i'm not gonna
try to make you do it and please don't
try to make me not do it that's right
there there's your clearest boundary
yeah and because either one of those are
gonna cause a problem and we're going to
have it we're going to have conflict and
i don't want to have conflict with you i
just want to love you
and there's no point in the conflict
because you're grown people you're
allowed to do whatever you want to do
even if you're wrong
i mean i got
i got relatives that vote wrong oh
heard and and i love them anyway that's
true i'm sure it's okay they just don't
know how to vote and you know
no amount of talking to them helps
either no so i just quit i quit arguing
with him a long time ago and i just know
my vote got cancelled out by so-and-so
you know that's they just don't know how
to vote and so you just can't there's
something you just can't argue about
done doing good jimmy's with us in
california hi jimmy how are you
doing great you did better than i
deserve how can we help
i'm calling because i have a quick
question my wife and i are on baby step
number two
uh we recently just sold our condo uh
made a profit of around seventy five
thousand dollars uh in the bank right
now we have 185.
uh the issue is we have
and 170 thousand dollars in student
loans
uh my question is
would you save a large chunk of that
we're looking at a home around six
hundred thousand uh save twenty percent
of that for a down payment or would you
pay place a large sum of that towards
the student loan debt did i understand
you have 185 in the bank 170 in student
loan debt
yes yes you did okay
uh well what we teach folks is don't buy
a house until you're debt free and have
an emergency fund
okay so i think you're renting for a
while because i think you just used 170
of your 185 to become debt free yeah
ow you're not gonna do that are you
well i mean crying
he's laughing like it's the most
ludicrous thing he's ever heard
[Laughter]
well you know as ludicrous as it sounds
it also kind of did just for a second
when i said that did you feel kind of
free
yes yes that would be amazing yeah i
mean you have to admit down inside your
stomach that something was set free when
i said that down inside your soul
something was set free because that 170
looks like it's insurmountable it looks
like freaking mount everest and for just
a second i placed you on top of mount
everest and you were cheering for just a
second and then you started rolling your
eyes and going i think this goes crazy
hey jimmy jimmy are you jimmy do you
have a good job you gainfully employed
yeah so i'm an ic registered nurse and
my wife is the emergency department here
what's your household income
uh we are around 160. why did it go oh
my gosh
jimmy here's a fun exercise for you you
and your wife tonight dinner okay write
down
what it would look like what would your
financial situation look like if you
paid the 170 off you had 15k you're
living in an rv
right yeah and then you got really good
income what would life look like i think
you just got to get over it
yeah you gotta write it down on paper
and look how fast could you save a
hundred grand oh my goodness
um we paid off to this was before i knew
about your program yeah we paid off like
two forty thousand dollar cars and like
within a year yeah so i think you could
save a hundred grand a year
[Applause]
and i think you're gonna be in a house
by this time next year
and you're gonna have an emergency fund
and no student loan debt
and you're gonna look back 10 years
later and go that crazy guy on the radio
is right because
if you don't do this you're going to
limp for a decade
hey you tell people what to do all the
time in your business
and they either do it or they don't this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if you've not heard the ken coleman
show it is broadcast on siriusxm 75 plus
radio stations and a podcast and a
youtube channel every day it's all about
finding your
path
to your dream
job finding your path through your
career and ken coaches people looking
for new jobs how to move up in their
current jobs how to find their giftings
and align with it and it is working so
ken talks about the workplace all the
time
ken one of the things i'm seeing right
now is this all this talk about burnout
and
coming back from
the pandemic a lot of people are going
back to jobs that they hated and they
realize now how bad they hate them and
they're quitting like crazy we're seeing
a huge number of people quitting their
jobs they call some people are calling
it the great resignation
but if you ask someone
if they love the work they do they
oftentimes say yes and they really
they're lying why do they do that
well there's something about uh what
other people think you know we've seen
this happen more so in the pandemic than
i think any time in modern history where
we just are so worried about being
criticized and questioned and so it's
almost a little bit of the old golden
handcuffs you got a good job with good
benefits
good pay and the idea of moving on to
something else is is is almost scoffed
at and you know we talk a lot about this
on the ken coleman show we've got seven
stages a very clear path and stage five
is is one that people really need to
grasp grasp certainly people that listen
to this show it's called get promoted
and this is the idea of moving up the
professional ladder and there's two
benefits dave to getting promoted
certainly when you get promoted most of
the time you're talking about getting
more income and that helps us with uh
whatever stage that we're in in the baby
steps right that bigger shovel is
applied throughout the baby steps right
we always need the bigger shovel but the
other thing dave is that
we long to do work that really matters
deeply to us we want to be challenged
and if we're not getting promoted
if we're not growing professionally then
we're not growing personally you're
dying if you're not growing you're dying
there's nothing there is there is no i'm
going to sit here and do the same work
for 38 years that's right because your
work deteriorates oh yeah you cannot do
the same work for 38 years at some point
you you master it you're going to do
better or you're going to do worse yeah
you're not going to do the same that's
right and so if you did now listen my my
parents generation certainly my
grandfather's generation the greatest
generation they would work the same job
for 30 to 40 years those days are over
the job is okay but the work's different
the work has changed and then you know
what's really cool these younger
generations certainly the millennials
begin to introduce this
but the the generation after them these
gen z kids
they really want to do something that
matters deeply to them personal values
and i think that's a really nice thing
to see but this idea of well i'm burned
out and i don't want to do that at work
anymore that's not true uh dave i just
posted something last week on instagram
at ken coleman and it was a clip from
the show the ken coleman show where i
was talking about a news article that
shows there is a huge percentage of
teachers that are planning to resign
this year and next year because of the
administrative demands on them the focus
on on um aptitude scores uh and things
of that nature that have nothing to do
with the kids grades it's all about
they're tired
teaching social agendas instead of
teaching academics that's the third
piece they now are being
forced to teach something that is
politically a real hot potato and so
they're going oh
i i can't do it anymore and and what you
have to understand there is if that's
you no matter what profession you're in
you still love the work but the
environment itself is what you need to
change not necessarily the profession
understand that you could be
what i call in the sweet spot where
you're using your talent to do work you
love to produce results of matter but if
you're in a crappy environment
uh that'll get old quick and you'll want
to change location so dave in this great
resignation that they're reporting that
you mentioned 40 percent their
economists are predicting 40 percent of
the american workforce will change jobs
in 2021.
good lord don't
don't please please please please don't
just move uh to something else because
of a paycheck
make sure that you love the work because
i can't tell you many times i'll get a
call from somebody say well i got a
promotion ken and i took it and i'm
miserable yeah you gotta love the work
and you gotta care about the results of
the work don't come to ramsey solutions
and work here if you don't care deeply
about providing hope
through practical content that is
transformational
don't come here because that's what we
bleed over here and and if you can't get
excited about that
it's just a job for you and we don't
want you and you won't want to be here
yeah that's exactly right and
it is it's actually a a job requirement
here that's got to be a crusader that
you care yeah and so we're hiring 300
folks this year and one of the things
we're interviewing for is uh are you
going to care deeply and do you care
deeply about what it is you're going to
be doing and how and where you're going
to be doing it and so um because i the
last thing i want to be giving people my
money who don't care yeah and then
because they always mail it in yeah
they're not creative they're not
productive they don't they're not game
on it will be a train stop for them yeah
and i don't i don't have time it's too
expensive to hire people and bring them
in here and move them out it's just too
expensive it's too expensive emotionally
that's right because i i i fall in love
with i love the people and then they
leave and it breaks my heart and so i
can't you know i'd rather just get folk
that actually karen are going to stay
that's a better plan and so that ought
to be you whether you're coming here or
anywhere else is what ken's saying yeah
don't have the train stop mentality have
the latter mentality all right so i am i
am moving towards that dream job where i
am just absolutely in my sweet spot i'm
using my top talents to do tasks and
functions or fill a role that i look
forward to and it creates a result that
personally connects to my values these
are the things i want to contribute that
has to be
it has to be always the litmus test for
what am i choosing and this idea of
getting promoted dave stage five
is all about moving up the ladder
because here's what happens we saw it
with our debt-free screamer
we see it all the time when i get
focused on on just the debt snowball we
see people get promoted and make more
money but what if you were focused on
not just making more money but doing
work that you love you're going to see
income and impact dave both of them move
up and that's what everybody longs to do
is to make a difference instead of a
j-o-b and it occurs to me that even in a
given position you can
everything's changing so fast quickly
the technology's changing the
methodology is changing the delivery
mechanisms are changing um i mean we
didn't you know i couldn't even spell
podcast a few years ago and now 12
million of you listen to this podcast
you know uh on this show and we've had
10 million on the radio for years
but uh it you know so yeah
all of a sudden we've got young people
that were broadcast people that are now
podcast people all in this building
working on our podcast all the time and
so you could be you could have started
here
uh
and you're still doing the same job but
you're doing it a different way with new
technology and have gotten and that is a
form of promotion absolutely and so
there is a clear path we're excited dave
we got a big announcement coming soon a
book that's going to reveal all seven
stages in the clear path to doing work
you love very exciting ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month to get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data with no
contract the average family saves over
seventy dollars a month by switching to
pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today nathan is in richmond
virginia hi nathan how can we help
hi how are you doing better than i
deserve what's going on
okay so here's what i got going on um
i'm 25 years old i'm getting money from
my father who recently passed away it's
going to be over 200 000
i'm not the best in money management
i've heard the saying it takes money to
make money should i invest this money
into a business should i save this money
what should i do if i want to become a
millionaire by the time i'm in my 30s um
how long ago did your dad pass away
nathan
um he passed away a couple months ago
i'm sorry y'all close
um we were pretty close he had dimension
alzheimer's so i didn't see him
um too often because he was in a
assisted living facility sure
and i lived across the country so he was
in arizona with my sisters and then i
lived over here in virginia
so you're getting 200 000 cash
it's not over that
it is just over that
yeah i'm not sure of the exact number i
mean it's just it's not it's not on a
piece of property or something else it's
just it's a investments or cash that's
going to come to you liquid that you're
going to do whatever you want to do with
it
yes like my brother's going to hand me a
check gotcha okay and uh what do you
make a year now
so a year i used to make around i'd say
35 000 a year okay all right
so here's what i would tell you um
you're calling
very very wisely to start to gather some
wisdom about something you don't know
anything about you have never driven a
car before and someone just gave you car
keys
right cool
and you go well i hear these things go
fast
right
and so
uh you know that
and yet if you remember the first time
you got behind the wheel of a car
uh it was both freeing
because you could now go places and
control your own destiny and it was uh
terrifying
and if you don't have both of those
feelings with this process you're not
wise
right okay so uh i'll start with it
takes money to make money uh is not a
true statement that's a statement that
broke people say as an excuse to not
become broke people
can you make money using money sure
but actually the vast majority of people
who build wealth do not build it because
someone handed them 200 000 they built
it because of their habits and their
character
okay so that's you
so here's what we're going to do we're
going to just what number one i tell you
is just slow way down
uh i would want you to move along the
spectrum from exciting to boring over
towards boring
your job is to manage this money
your job as if it's someone else's money
and you're managing it for them your job
first is not to lose it
your job second
is to maximize it
but most people when they get handed the
keys to the car
step on the gas
and mean it meaning they're they think
their job is to maximize it and they end
up losing it
so people yeah people that end up in
your situation get money lose it very
often because they make the mistake of
they think it has to be exciting it has
to be sexy it has to be wild has to be
crazy because if i don't maximize it i'm
doing something wrong it takes money to
make money we all know that and so i'm
going to invest it over here and i'm
going to do this i'm going to do that
and i'm going to do this
wrong
slow down
number one rule nathan don't put money
in something you don't understand
don't put money in something someone
else tells you is a good idea and they
sound like they're really smart people
around the money business and i've been
around at 40 years
there are a lot of enthusiastic
ignoramuses
they mean well but they're dumber than a
rock
and they're excited about and they're
excited about their stupidity and they
will put you in stuff they'll put you in
stuff man and all your broke friends
also got an opinion already don't they
yeah and here's another piece too i
started a meat company but the thing
about it when i started this meat
company it's not my passion because i
was so money hungry to where i let money
kind of consume my mind
of oh i need to make my i need to make
money i need to be this by the time on
this age
i chased things that weren't my passion
and then i realized as i got into it i'm
like shoot i don't want to do this
anymore okay so let me let's take a
couple things number one we can work on
your career and that would be a good use
of a little of this money
if it got you into your passion i'll
hand off to ken in a minute and let him
work on that okay but then thing two
uh here's a rule if you were to invest
this money
and not touch it
in good growth stock mutual funds
and if it made 10
rate of return on average
in seven years it would double you would
have 400
and you would be what 29 years old right
no how do you say you're 25
25 yeah yeah okay so you'll be 32 years
old and f in seven more years it would
double again it'd be 800 000.
and in seven more years it would double
again and it'd be a million six
and that is a boring never touch it
investment program you're probably not
going to do exactly that but i want a
little of that in the formula here my
brother
okay where you go have a life and you
pretend you don't have this money and
you let it grow and double and grow and
double and grow and double and so here
my my last piece of instruction before
ken helps you on the career side is
uh i want you to go to dave ramsey.org
to ramseysolutions.com and click on
smart vester sit down with the smart
investor pro and they will teach you
about mutual funds and then you can
decide
how much of this needs to go into your
career changes
and how much of it needs to go
into
mutual funds and that just sit there and
just double so ken yeah real quick
question here is the meat company that
you started is that what's getting you
the 35 000 a year
yes all right and so you don't want to
do that what do you want to do i know
you got some ideas or one clear idea
what is it that you really want to do
so i really want to do fitness um
because even in the times when i was at
my lowest i always stuck to it yep and
it seems like it was like introduced to
me great at a young age so is that uh is
that a fitness coach
trainer is that what we're talking about
so i want to compete in shows and i want
to launch
i want to be able to get a following
through the instagram and be able to
launch a business online and help people
reach their fitness goals
yeah online because everything is online
now sure um and also you know even in
person but doing it online it gives you
that freedom to do the travel all right
so
let me make sure i heard this right you
want to be a fitness competitor and then
eventually develop some type of online
and in-person training business that's a
two-parter am i right
yes okay so here's the deal i'm gonna
caution you on this being a fitness
competitor is a whole different ballgame
we only can make money when we win so if
that's the first goal you're going to
need a day job so you got to sit down
and go now what's the best strategy
here's what i would challenge you to
think through
i would you're clear on what you want to
do that's stage one of my seven stages
stage twos get qualified
so you need to answer the question what
is it that i need to do to get qualified
to train people online now online
there's no technical qualification you
just gotta have good content that people
say all right i'm gonna watch this guy
and i'm gonna train the way he trains
but if you want to do it one-on-one
there's some qualification that you need
how much is that going to cost you how
long is that going to take
we're going to have to have a day job
still in all of this process so if
you've got the meat cooker a personal
trainer could be a personal trainers
where i would go into so get qualified
to do that get in the proximity that's
it start doing that and then compete and
any money we make competing and the
online business it's going to grow over
time i would get in the field work for a
gym um and have somebody else pay you to
do the training so that you can move
from meat company into this job and not
interrupt the income because dave we
don't want him to touch yeah this 200
000 nathan i want you to take 24 000 of
the 200 hundred thousand set aside for a
year's worth of two thousand dollars a
month yeah i want you to pay yourself
out of a little savings account two
thousand dollars each month for one year
during that year i want you to develop a
real
group of uh one-on-one personal training
clients that pay you well and you use
that money to eat with
then you will also perfect your training
techniques meanwhile you get to work out
like a crazy person for your own
uh competition goals
and uh let's build a training business
then build an online business while
we're competing
and i think that's an order and a way to
get at this and use a little bit of the
money to do that and let's invest the
rest of it and not don't be spending a
bunch of money on unproven business
ideas or trying to buy a franchise on a
business out of a box you're not in a
position to do that yet you got to get
some more notches in your belt
this is the ramsey shack
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage evan and alyssa are with
us hey guys how are you doing great good
welcome where do you guys live
germantown wisconsin milwaukee area
that's right yeah good good to have you
guys welcome all the way to nashville to
do a debt-free scream how much have you
paid off
103 000 just just north of 103 000 good
how long did that take you um about 36
months good and your range of income
during that time
uh it ranged from 120 to 170. good what
do you guys do for a living i work at an
i'm a sales executive for a large
insurance company
and then i was working at a bank and
with financial advisors okay good very
cool so both of your numbers people
around the numbers were oh for sure what
kind of debt was the 103
yeah the majority was uh student loans
we had a 2013 camaro sitting in the
driveway and a 2018 honda civic that we
got rid of along the way as well but the
majority student loans and a little bit
of credit card debt on top of it so you
sold both those cars uh we sold the
honda civic actually to our grandparents
that kind of kicked us off and we're
thankful for that i think they paid a
little bit above market just to help us
on the way that's nice yeah yeah and
then uh cabarro ended up turning it into
a 2005 sierra that we still have to this
day paid and paid full so oh wow okay
wow good for you
so what happened 36 months ago what
starts this journey for y'all yeah you
know we we pretty much were just
thinking hey we're going to be we're
going to be cuffed to these student
loans for the next 10 years and these
car payments the next five and never put
too much thought to it but
the place i worked at the time a friend
of mine joel i know he's i know he's
listening back home he came to me one
day and said you ever hear this book
total money makeover no this guy dave
ramsey
said no he said well you know i was
listening yesterday and this uh this
girl paid off 90 000 of student loans in
two years and there's people paying off
their mortgages in four to five years so
um immediately that got my that my whole
sense of the light bulb goes yeah
there's a different way to do this yeah
that'd be cool that's what your mind
says that'd be neat yeah
i run home and i'm all jacked up you
know and uh
bring the idea to alyssa and wow you
know why would we do that why don't we
put ourselves through that stress and we
went to a restaurant locally
jotted down a bunch of notes about what
was coming out every month and
then on a different piece of paper wrote
down a bunch of goals that we had over
the next you know five ten years and
we noticed we can't have three thousand
dollars going out every month the
student loan payments and debt payments
and accomplish these things at the same
time so we gotta we gotta figure
something out okay but i'll be honest i
was not fully bought in sure so it took
a i told them i will you know entertain
this for you and we'll see how it goes
for the next couple months okay um but
after the you know these couple months
it was like why have we never lived like
this before it really
it was hard at first but it wasn't you
know a huge life change i didn't it
didn't kill you no no we're still here
and you can see your way out exactly if
you can see your way out and it doesn't
kill you you'll do it yeah so you went
picked up the total money makeover book
yourself after the restaurant i did yep
yep and that's that's been passed
through the family now so um that's
another thing about our midwest
upbringing it's a conservative you know
we don't talk about money but alyssa and
i going through this journey has all of
a sudden opened up those lines of
communication our family and her family
and it's just been a serious blessing
for for everybody that's come in contact
with us so throughout the journey so
it's been really special yeah you've
inspired people it's what amounts to
yeah that's why we're here you know
we're not just here to celebrate our our
debt free screen but if we can make an
impact on one person listening in i mean
it's
the weight of this i have a new found
respect for folks in on that lobby
waiting for their debt free scream we
were laughing crying over the last you
know hour or so so and getting nervous
about getting the microphone yeah yeah
you're doing great though you're doing
great okay i've got a relationship
question yeah uh because
for a married couple you know it's this
has got to be a joint deal
and alyssa i love what you said you said
okay we we go to the diner or wherever
you go and you're we got two pieces of
paper okay and alyssa i love it you said
well i i wasn't bought in but i was like
all right i'm open-minded would you
speak
to the importance of that relationship
component if one of the spouses is like
i don't know yet but given it a chance
because that seemed to be really big for
you because you saw it
yeah i would say i mean you know evan
has a lot of crazy ideas i think
but go evan
this time i was like you know this
actually sounds like something that
would help us in the future
when he brought the ideas to me i just
didn't want to have to do a big life
change i think it's scary you know you
all of a sudden i can't you know go get
something at the store i feel like i
can't spend money
i didn't want to have to feel guilty
about making purchases
but when he really showed me you know
and we started doing it it was a lot
easier than i thought there was things
that we didn't even know where half of
our spending was going yeah so when we
really wrote it down and um having me
bought in
brought our whole relationship even to
the next level i feel like um you know
we were both on the same page i do know
some people who want to pay off all
their debt and they don't have their
spouse you know bought in and i said it
may not work you know you really have to
have that person that has the same drive
as you we'd both log our spending you
know in the app um you both have to be
determined to do it yeah yeah
you weren't resistant but you just
wanted to prove out because he brought
you other schemes of scams
sharon says that she says you're
scheming and scamming
no i'm not doing either one i'm just
having a discussion here woman
a big driving factor you know one of the
things on that list was she's always
wanted to become a stay-at-home mom when
we had kids
and you know anybody that's ever seen
her be a mother will tell you she's the
she's built for it you know she is the
best mother that you'll ever see
and um as a result of this pro this
program that we stuck to over the last
three years we've been able to
accomplish that goal for her and um yeah
i got her on board you know once you
start talking like that yeah there you
go that's great yeah you know here's
another thing you you you
made it personal for her it wasn't just
about your big idea and that you got
fired up from the book you tapped into
her future desired future her dreams
look at the tears on her she loves meet
obama i mean that's what it's about
that's financial peace right there for
sure yeah for you not to get uh i'm
hoping i'd get through without getting
emotional like her but um you asked the
the last debt free scream uh
what made it worth it for you right
um
there was a situation we were we were
coming up towards the very end of our
journey and we had our son in daycare
she was working part-time just to make
some more money so we could kind of
speed this thing along and again her her
whole goal was
become a stay-at-home mother our second
baby was due in a month at this point
yep so we're in stork mode as you guys
call it i think we had like 30 grand
sitting in the bank account and
we're just working out the numbers to
figure out how we can make this all
happen at once have the baby debt free
stay at home you know
and about a month before we were about
to pull our son from daycare we get a
call it's a great day care we still have
friends there uh to this day that we
that we love talking to on a regular
basis and we'd be we'd go back there you
know but they had a situation where our
two-year-old was left out they go to the
playground
they left our son out you know
it was it was a really short period of
time it's like five minutes he was like
hidden on a playhouse where they
couldn't see him yeah
and um you know
i think about my boy being out there
alone and scared and um
we had and they called you and told you
about it they admitted it yeah they were
they called us you know
was it was a regulation put on them by
the state and they stuck to it we
appreciate that and we're still good
friends with the owner of that yeah well
i mean everybody makes a mistake but
that goes okay you're done yep i'm done
and because of where we were you could
you could pull the trigger yeah i got a
call at 10 o'clock in the morning i was
at that daycare at 11 taking my son out
he's never gone back and when when
people ask alyssa what she does for a
living and then my son's next to her he
says i stay home with mommy
and uh you know
it's just it's just such a it's such a
the weight was it's really rewarding
that we were able to do that and now he
can you know i can hang out with him
every day and we do fun things every day
yeah that's worth 103 000 and anything
you sacrifice to get rid of it all day
yeah that's a good that's a check well
written right there
well done guys i love it you guys are
amazing thank you you're inspiring so
fun
so fun so the key well we ain't even got
time i'm not gonna do it i'm gonna give
you a copy of the total total money
makeover to give away so somebody that's
at a restaurant somewhere doing their
goals probably needs a copy of that book
you're going to run into them and we'll
give you a copy of the legacy journey
because you definitely have changed your
family tree in so many different ways in
this story so inspiring so well done you
guys thank you all right evan and alyssa
milwaukee wisconsin area 103 000 paid
off in 36 months make it 120 to 170.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three three two one we're dead
[Applause]
you want to stay home with your kiddos
[Applause]
touchdown
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure you
pick the wrong color they will remake
your window blinds for free they have
free samples free shipping new promos
all the time always use the magic word
the promo code ramsey to get you a deal
today's question dave comes from javier
in california he writes in i currently
have a job in construction management
which pays a hundred thousand dollars a
year plus bonuses my dream since i was a
kid was to become a police officer but
the money i've been making has pushed me
away from this goal i don't get the
satisfaction with my current job that i
think i would have as a police officer
but i'm scared to make a change
which might be a mistake what should i
do javi here
you should follow your heart on this but
before we follow the heart let's do a
little bit more research
what i call clarify and verify you've
probably done this but i'd love for you
to talk to a couple police officers who
really love their work
and this is over coffee could be over
zoom whatever and sit down with them and
learn what do they love most about the
work what do they like the least and
let's just do a little simple
almost term paper-like research with
real men and women who are winning and
love being a police officer once we get
that information that's to clarify your
heart is going to verify verify and say
hey this is something i need to do now
it's all about getting qualified and so
you know what that journey looks like or
you need to find out from them so what
is actually involved what do i need to
do to get qualified what's that process
going to look like and now we have a
clear path to getting qualified and so
you make really good money you save up
for any kind of cost here in the
qualification stage and you go for it
you're going to make the transition and
here's the deal dave i know this that
anytime somebody makes a change even
when their heart like javier is saying
he's always wanted to be a police
officer to protect and to serve
but it's scary when we don't know what
the journey might look like and so when
we go figure out what the journey is
going to look like in getting qualified
and then
what does it look like it's not so scary
there's two pieces to that to me
listening to you explain it through it
feels like that
um if i get real clear of exactly what
it looks like when i get there and then
i get really clear
on exactly what it's going to take to
get there that's exactly right the fear
goes away yeah because now we know oh
okay
i'm going to have to get physically fit
because i've got to pass a test for this
so i've got some goals i've gotta hit
i'm gonna have to go through the academy
through the academy maybe three four
months and then maybe there's a six
month probation period where they bring
me in whatever that particular apartment
looks like that's what we're talking
about what does it take to actually get
in and then when you're doing the job
yeah here's what the glorious parts are
but here's the inglorious parts yeah you
know like i know one lady that kept
saying she wanted to be a nurse and then
she went and shadowed a nurse for two
days and she went ew i don't want to do
that that's right that's the clarify
verify once we actually see what it's
like
what are the best parts do some
ride-alongs with some patrol guys you
know we had a policeman call me today on
the coleman show earlier today and he
was wanting to transition because of the
environment that unfortunately exists
today
in america around policemen and it's not
the case for everybody but there's
certainly a really rough environment
and so i really pressed him on it and i
said what do you love most about being a
police officer and his answer was i
really like being a part of saving
someone's life whether i'm doing it or
assisting an emt or a fireman or
whatever because it's really about
protecting people for me
and and i think that what he was trying
to do is say hey ken should i leave
because of the environment and i said if
you can find something else that allows
you to do the work of protecting or
caregiving
then yes but if not stay
and in this situation before you make
that move you really want to clarify and
verify does this set my heart on fire am
i doing work that i love am i producing
results that matter deeply to me very
simple questions
and if you look into it the answers take
away the fear of the unknown because we
know oh this is what it's going to be
like and this is what it's going to take
to get there now i can wrap my brain
around it just like dave for years is
giving you folks seven baby steps oh a
thousand dollars baby step one i gotta
put a thousand dollars for rainy day
you know the either the debt snowball oh
there's a plan absent of a plan
fear will paralyze us yep yeah but
knowledge gives you power absolutely
when you when you know what it's going
to be like when you get there and you
know exactly what the steps are the fear
largely dissipates it really does but
most of your fear comes from the unknown
yes sir open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
rachel's in orange county california hi
rachel welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much this is like my
fourth and fifth time calling and i'm
excited every time well we're honored to
have you again how can we help thank you
okay so
um in january this year i paid off two
car collections that i had from about
six to seven years ago
um
and so one of them is not on my credit
report anymore the other one for toyota
i had to dispute twice and it finally
shows that i paid a lesser amount than
what was actually due
however it's still showing up on my
credit report and it's saying it'll be
on there until february of next year
that's because that's what happened
okay so they keep that on record for a
year after i mean as long you settled it
for less than was owed right
correct i got all in writing yeah so and
and they're reporting they're reporting
it accurately although it is a negative
report
okay is that correct
yes okay yeah you can't do anything
about something that's reported
accurately
okay but they're they're saying it's
gonna drop off in a year
yeah it says on file until february of
2022. oh great
because yeah but another way they can
another way they can choose to do it is
seven years from the date of last
activity on the account and the last
activity on the account was when you
settled it it could have been seven
years from the other day but the good
news is it's about to run out anyway so
it's going to go away
but there's not really anything you can
do about it because you can only dispute
things on a credit bureau report that
are inaccurate
correct
and this is accurate so you're stuck
with it and the great news is it's going
to go away automatically in a year
anyway because apparently that's seven
years ago that you had this repo or had
the problem or established the account
or something because it's a seven-year
rule the only thing that stays on your
credit bureau report longer than seven
years is a chapter seven bankruptcy
which will stay on for 10 years
but everything else drops off in seven
years from the date of last activity
uh and so it literally can be
you you pay an old bad bill this week
seven years from this week it goes off
that it can be but apparently sometimes
the credit it's up to the creditor as to
how they report it but apparently the
creditor here is reporting it from the
date the loan was initially made or the
date that it went into default or
something yeah rachel i just want to
encourage you hey you're walking out the
baby steps so this isn't going to be a
factor for you anyway number one it
doesn't stain you number two you don't
need it because you're going to pay cash
for things so let this thing i love the
intensity and i love the enthusiasm and
the deep passion here but this is not a
big stain that's going to hold you back
it's going to fall off and you're doing
all the right things really really proud
of you keep after it yeah
here's
to ken's point um and it's not what you
were saying so i'm not correcting you
but i just want our listening audience
to hear this clearly uh we don't worship
at the altar of the great fico right
your fico score is an indication of how
much money you have borrowed and paid
back
it is not an indication of wealth
let me try that again your fico score is
how much the larger your fico score the
more you've been playing kissy face with
the bank
or kissy something
and so you got to decide you're going to
play kissy with the bank all the time
you can have a big old fico score and
keep them rich if you were gonna quit
borrowing money your fico score
literally does not matter you know what
my fico score is i don't have one
it's zero because i haven't borrowed
money shame shame shame on you dave you
have not maximized the american way yes
i have i've got several hundred million
dollars is working out for me so you
know this is you know th this is but
you're right that you know it doesn't
matter who cares that it's on there
she's moving on yeah yeah she
then i think that's a good point but
also a good point to say she's doing
really good stuff by really watching
what's going on with it and getting the
proper things on there the proper things
off of there i did all of that too i
wanted to make sure mine was cleaned off
because
uh you know after i went through a
bankruptcy it stayed on there 10 years
wow you know yeah and so i yeah but you
know what i never borrowed money again
so it really didn't come up that's
exactly right and she did it right she
got it in writing the settlement she's
doing everything the right way yeah
she's just really cleaning things up
good for you good job rachel well played
well played ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host this hour good
hour ken thank you sir good job kelly
and ben in the booth i am dave ramsey
your host we will be back before you
know it
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book the
proximity principle is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about career
about money about life
and about life
it's a free call some say the advice is
worth what you pay for it the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five
two two five lee's with us in cleveland
ohio hi lee how are you
hi dave um hang well how are you better
than i deserve what's up
um okay so we recently relocated from
florida to ohio and we sold our home in
florida and we thought we'd be able to
buy our house in cleveland for cash but
with this market that's proving to be
very difficult we have about three
hundred and fifty thousand three hundred
fifty to four hundred thousand dollars
to spend cash um but should we rent for
a year and hope the market at least
comes or should we get a small mortgage
well neither one is in the dumb column
yes um it's just a matter of what for me
personally once i made the decision to
never be in debt it would be very hard
for me emotionally
to take out a mortgage again but
mathematically it wouldn't be that big a
deal for you
yeah and that's what we're thinking like
we've worked really hard we have we're
debt-free fully funded emergency fund
have about a million dollars in
investments we're in our young
young 40 um so i just
the million dollars is in investments is
it all in retirement
it's all retirement yeah you can't touch
it congrats and you said you're 40.
actually 42 and you're everyday
millionaires way to go yeah
thanks thank you very much
it's been a long road but it's you know
i grew up with you so it was uh it was
an easy road so well we're honored so
your baby steps millionaires then good
okay so
what uh uh uh wow so what's your
household income
um with my i'm a stay-at-home mom i
would say about 200 with bonus
and so how much mortgage would you take
out if you went ahead and moved on a
property now i mean
honestly we wanted to stay in a house
that's around 350.
but you said you had 350 or 400
correct correct and that's all like i
don't want a monstrosity house but i
want help that's like updated in a good
neighborhood and those are you know 600
650 right now and it just to me you
don't seem a little dumb to spend that
kind of money so just i'm just
struggling with it like in florida i
expected it i didn't i i guess i didn't
expect it in cleveland ohio so much so
hmm
so you take out like a 200 000 mortgage
yeah yeah probably somewhere around
there and it would take you like three
years to clear
that probably yeah yeah
okay
well that's certainly not the end of the
world it's certainly not going to make
you go bankrupt and it's certainly not
going to keep you from building wealth
if you chose if you choose to go that
route i don't think you're going to see
the market calm down 200 000 in 12
months
right right but i i mean i guess our
thought was you know maybe we rent and
we stayed for another year and then we
have you know 500 grand to spend or
something and then at least we're not
like we put in bids on three homes and
we've been outbid like the we're we're
bidding ask and then they're coming back
after that and saying we want another
sixty thousand dollars and i'm like i
just i physically can't do it like it
makes me wanna vomit
i'm struggling well so um
and the bid on the three homes what was
the prices you bid
um we've been about 350. uh so you have
found home you have found homes that the
asking price on was a home that you
would buy
yes yes but we're getting outbid like i
understand i understand
but that's different than saying i have
to jump from 350 or 400 to 600 to buy a
house that's updated in cleveland ohio
those are those and those are
incongruent conclusions
yes yes you're correct on that you're
you're the one that's motivating on
there yeah i think
i think i think you're getting a little
bit into house fever drama mode maybe
maybe because you kicked up you kicked
up to 600 because you got outbid on a
350.
yeah but keep in mind i also have two
small children and right now we're
living in a hotel so that'll add to the
drama mode that'll add to the drama mode
that'll cause anybody to go crazy but
but um yeah i'll give i'll give you that
but i'm going to call you on your lack
of logic okay so
uh
and don't forget dave that if you pay if
you go for a 600 000 house you get in
the same market you're going to have
that whole back and forth there too yeah
so
what i'm going to do is go rent but i
want an out
in the lease
okay i want to be i want to i want terms
of the lease that allow me for x number
of dollars to break the lease and then i
want you to keep bidding on 350 and 400
000 houses until you actually get one
okay
and here and
what you have to do in that process is
you have to steal yourself your emotions
you have to put your shields up
and just kind of then be surprised
when you actually get one
you know what i'm saying
instead you like got married to these
other two and it was a deep
disappointment yeah yeah yeah so
i was i was on the golf green the other
day uh teeing off at the first uh hole
and i my i looked down at my cell phone
and uh an offer i had made that i fully
did not expect to go through on a
property i buy real estate
i looked down and i told sharon i said
damn come we just bought that house
i never dreamed it was like a surprise
because i figured in this market i was
going to get out bid i didn't figure i
was shocked
and uh you know and and so you kind of
want to be in that mode where you're
like pleasantly surprised that it
actually went through yes and meaning
that you're not deeply disappointed and
oh god the world's coming to an end i
got to go buy 600 000 house because my
offer didn't go through because you're
probably going to continue to see this
now i will tell you that the white hot
market
probably
apexed about 30 days ago
it's still hot
still quite hot but not as much as it
was 30 days ago we're seeing all kinds
of indicators coming back now the
different markets have different
personalities and certainly different
micro markets within markets even have
different personalities so there might
be a neighborhood or two where it's
still just going cray-cray but uh this
um
the the 17 offers all over asking price
by 50 grand
are not happening as much today as they
were 30 45 days ago
most places nashville's hot really hot
williamson county where we live outside
of nashville really hot but it slowed
down a little bit a little bit not not
it's not returned to completely normal
it's certainly not bargains everywhere
nothing like that
but uh the the lumber prices have come
down building is normalized somewhat and
so the frenzy
has seems to have peaked
in in some areas in most areas so i i'll
tell you that sometime in the next six
months you're going to find a house you
can buy for asking price that you like
this 350 to 400. that's why i want you
to have an out
in the lease i love that practical
advice takes all the pressure off you've
already negotiated upfront on the lease
you got the cash a bill to pay to break
the lease that really takes the pressure
off now it becomes a game yeah that's
fun and then you then you're pleasantly
surprised when it actually does work
yeah
this is the ramsey chat
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
healthcare coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at ch
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five well i've heard all the
excuses
that people have for putting off making
a will
i'm busy it's confusing
it's a downer it's morbid it's expensive
if i do a will i might die
that's that's my favorite yeah you're
gonna die
okay
100 mortality rate in the human race
okay
we've done detailed research you're
gonna die
you need a will
in fact ramsey solutions research team
found that 74 of parents don't have a
will come on guys
that's not good it's too important you
need a will to protect your family stop
putting it off get it done start with
our free
will preparation checklist
this guide helps you think through the
seven important areas like naming of
guardians
beneficiaries plus all the little things
you hadn't thought of
and once you've gone over the checklist
setting up your actual will will only
take you about 10 or 15 minutes
get the guide the free
will preparation checklist by texting
will
233
789 and you can start the morbid
uncomfortable conversation text will 233
789 give your family peace of mind by
getting yourself a will mine's so
stinking detail ken we have a meeting
once a year to go over all the estate
plan with the family and the leadership
team here i call it the monty python
meeting because we all discuss dave's
death and i always go i'm feeling much
better yeah it's just a flesh wound i
don't know how you do that when you tell
us that it's kind of that has to be
weird it's creepy as crud do you like
multiple times in the media remind
everybody that you're still in the room
other people do because it's awkward for
them
so like mark floyd our cfo goes i don't
like talking about this and he says this
every year for eight years now i don't
like talking about you dying and you
dying in front of you and i'm like well
you gonna talk about me behind my back
about dying i mean come on what is the
deal it's it's funny but uh it's it's uh
it's in in it is a matter of diligence
to get these things in place
because if you don't it costs your
family so much heartache yeah brandon is
with us brandon's in tampa florida hey
brandon how are you
hey dude how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
uh so i am contemplating switching jobs
and i wanted to give you a little detail
and see if you can help me to make an
informed decision okay
so i've worked for the same company for
15 years
i love my company and i think what i
like best about my job is i work from
home i have really flexible hours so one
of my kids has special needs if he's
meeting with a therapist
i can take a quick break from work and i
can meet with a therapist too or if they
have a function going on at school i can
meet them at school and i'm home every
night for dinner and then uh i can walk
back into work if i need to after
they're in bed so it kind of lets me be
super dad uh while you know my kids
still like me you know until they become
teenagers right
okay
so the uh
so why are you leaving why are you
leaving nirvana
so unless i move to another city they
won't let me apply for other jobs and
they're going to lay me off in the next
three months to three years
oh okay so this is the end i kind of
nirvana's in there you got kicked out of
the garden okay i
i will it's just kind of when do i pull
off the band-aid right
i i found another job that would
actually pay me more and it would have a
lot of job security and it'd be a great
job
but it's probably a two to two and a
half hour commute a day
and it would be a lot of hours and i
wouldn't be
home or able to do
any of this stuff with my kids
you have to move is what you have to do
yeah
two and a half hours
we're not doing a two and a half hour
commute that's a that's just asinine
yeah you would last more than three
months your heart your heart's already
telling you that's a bad idea that's
just your brain because you've got a
little bit of fear a little bit of
pressure so that's not an option unless
you move and then you said i'm not
willing to move why you're not willing
to move
uh my kids are in a great school
district love my house love my
neighborhood i have a rental in the same
street my in-laws live on the same
street
you haven't found the new job yet yeah
you got to keep looking there's a good
list of reasons why we say no to that
um
so i started looking for that other job
that i have in 2018
and i was getting ready to start that
job and then it went on hold during the
pandemic and they're trying to get me to
come back now
my wife and i kind of want to just wait
until we get laid off just so you know
i'm on baby step seven
i have a fully funded emergency fund and
a large chunk of money that's in our
checking account because we're getting
ready to buy a car
so financially
i'm in good shape where if i got laid
off it wouldn't be the end of the world
but
if and when i went to look for another
job it's very likely that i'd take a big
pay cut because the technology that i'm
working on is very proprietary so not a
lot of other places need it so i'd have
to kind of start at the ground what's
the place two and a half hours away with
a raise do they have the same
technology uh they do it's kind of a
government job so it's not just that
it's two and a half hours away it's that
it's uh
a long commute with traffic i got that
part i'm asking what was the job is it
the same technology
uh it's not that they're willing to take
me because of a security clearance all
right so what is your what would you say
is your uh type of work are you a
programmer are you inside give me a give
me a job title so i can have an idea of
what we're looking at here
being your systems engineer
uh one thing that's kind of funky is my
current company because i can't apply
for jobs they just move me wherever they
need me
so right now i'm not working on
technology i would apply to a job for
because i've been doing it since
february okay here's the deal in tampa
florida a great job market good size
area the systems engineer what you have
to start doing right now is start
finding other different types of
opportunities that allow you to take
your experience and your skill set those
are two different things but i think
you've got a wonderful future you know
the idea of waiting to be laid off
that's just not how i'm wired but
because you're in baby step seven and
you've gotta you've got a a whole
different perspective on things i'm not
gonna say that's not a good idea you
certainly can do it it's not but i don't
like it okay good i i don't like it i
think that that is uh too passive
and uh brandon you're in denial yeah
you're in denial that this nirvana is
going away it's going away and all you
have said all you have set up are these
impossible freaking scenarios that are
fatalistic all around you where your
life is not going to continue unless you
keep this job that's right and that's a
bunch of bs this you you have a skill
set that is totally marketable
within 30 minutes of your house and you
need to go look for a new position and
that what has happened dave those
excuses those are all excuses those
scenarios become excuses for him because
he doesn't want to leave the nirvana
because he doesn't want to leave them
i'm sorry but nirvana's ending yeah
they're kicking you out of the garden of
eden yeah you don't get to live there
anymore yeah and so it's they've told
you and and the instability of that is
is is eroding
you guys it's it's eating at you guys
and that's why you went and considered
something two and a half two and a half
hours no yeah that yeah and by the way
we just freaking moved to orlando oh my
god and you know what you don't have to
trade off being a super dad and being
there for your kids if your scenario
changes that again is a false choice
it's a false narrative and we do this we
create all these reasons why we should
sit tight
and in this situation he's so marketable
the opportunities for him are endless as
a systems engineer
i mean technology
that's the place to be and because he
can go just about anywhere yeah
you're going to be fine
you're going to be fine but
you know i'm just calling you on your
stuff here you know you you need to go
look for something that's not two and a
half hours away and if it's a little bit
of a pay cut so what it's um
you know and no i'm not going to sit and
wait on this to come hit me in the back
of the head we know it's coming and so
um you know
go land you something and get yourself
get yourself a projected future that
feels good again
you don't have a good feeling about your
projected future nothing in your future
that you laid out sounded fun
nothing did
and that's just not accurate there's a
way to put together a life that you love
here again
and
so amen appreciate you glad you're at
baby step seven proud of you for doing
that it gives you some options gives you
some comfort don't wallow in the comfort
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage isabella is here hi
isabella how are you hi dave i'm doing
great thank you guys for having me today
we're honored to have you where do you
live likewise i live in los angeles
california a bit of a haul over to
nashville welcome good to have you and
how much debt have you paid off isabella
i paid off thirty four thousand four
hundred and seventy three dollars and 82
cents awesome how long did this take you
12 months 12 months and your range of
income during that time it was about 56
and it ended around 60. cool okay what
kind of debt was the 34 000. the
majority of my debt was student loans
okay and a little bit of credit card it
was all student loans what do you do for
a living i'm in real estate now i just
actually passed my real estate license
last month and so i've been doing real
estate for a few months now in
california what were you doing before
that for the 56 to 60. before that i was
actually in international education
and i was doing that for the full year
and i was also
doing some part-time jobs as well to
supplement my income to
be really gazelle intense and focused to
pay off the student loans good for you
how old are you i'm 30 am i going to be
31 tomorrow actually tomorrow's like
okay well happy birthday thank you very
cool thank you okay so something
happened i mean your 20s goes away we're
sitting on 30
or so 29 or 30 and we're looking down
and there's this nagging student loan
that won't go away what happened what
was the breakthrough
well it was actually started a few years
before that actually um i
was teaching in china actually so i was
there for about four years wow and i
thought i want i wanted to go into
government work as a foreign service
officer and so that's why i went to go
get my master's and then i had an
internship
in hong kong and i decided that i really
liked what i was doing at the time but i
didn't see myself doing it long term i
would rather be focused more on the
business side entrepreneurial side
and so i left and
china and i came back to the states and
i believe it was 2015.
[Music]
and i really started to get gazelle
tense in uh 2019.
um
earlier that year my mother passed away
actually um really unexpectedly and so
that was kind of the catalyst for me to
really get my affairs in order and
really
focus on something that i know she would
be extremely proud
about
and also for me you know i was working
in education at the time and i was like
how should i have debt over my head when
i'm being in this field i'm coaching
students and so i i really wanted to
clean up my backyard essentially yeah
yeah that's that's powerful
there's something about um a friend of
mine a pastor friend of mine and i were
speaking at a funeral a while back and
he made a comment i've never forgotten
he said uh
losing someone a a funeral a birth
either one are both tuning forks
and you re-tune your life because you
we're all get real introspective when
those kinds of things happen and the
loss of your mom does that and says okay
this life thing is short i better get it
right for sure for sure and so later
that year actually i
started financial peace university at a
church
and i brought my sister along with me
and it was it was funny she made a
comment she was 21 at the time and she's
like i'm too young for this i shouldn't
be going to this and i was just telling
her actually this is like the perfect
time that you should be learning about
this so you can grow and invest earlier
and so i dragged her along with me and i
finished the course
at the end of 2019 and then in 2020 in
march that's when i got really focused
yeah and that's when i was beans and
rice rice and beans i was doing whatever
i could to get out of debt and it was
really hard because i went through
actually you know several losses um i
actually was going through a breakup at
the time too so there was a lot of times
where it was you know during the
pandemic as well where everything just
really seemed really difficult a lot of
stress right a lot of stress like loss
and stuff but i always push myself to
this that this season is not going to
last forever and that's when i would
always listen to your podcast i took a
lot of inspiration from other debt
stream
people as well and listening to your
podcast when i would drive to and from
work and that would always keep me
focused whenever i just didn't want to
work so hard or times where i just felt
like it was kind of insurmountable uh
listening to you and other people really
was something that kept me focused on
the past for sure so i want to ask you
how did this i mean i love that story
unbelievable grit so proud of you
how did that journey that that singular
focus on getting out of debt how did it
play into you becoming a real estate
professional and kind of scratching that
entrepreneurial itch because this i'm
assuming this was all part of the
transition getting debt free and moving
into real estate yes my so my last
position um it was a means to an end so
it was a means for me to get out of debt
once i got out of debt um earlier this
year actually i was like i want to get
my real estate license and so uh it took
me six and a half months from when i
started to when i passed to actually get
it done so when i paid off my debt i was
able to
i went online and i fill out the
questionnaire for dave ramsey to be here
to get the debt free screen and then
after that i took my real estate exam
and i passed so it was just kind of
everything just kind of happened like a
domino effect so i love this dave this
is day job the dream job there's nothing
wrong with a day job right that gets us
out of debt that prepares us while we're
getting qualified for the dream job
great job good for you now have you sold
your first house yet i've sold actually
four already yeah
touchdown how does that feel it feels
amazing and i actually um had like a
mid-year review with one of my mentors
at uh at
my company and he was saying um that you
know that he's kind of impressed about
how quick i and i'm learning the ropes
and i told him this is the first time
actually i've ever had a job that i felt
like matched my personality so well yeah
that's great and uh it feels great it's
like you make your own schedule you go
in when you want to you leave when you
when you want to
and
your results are reflected on how much
effort and how hard you push yourself
yeah who'd you bring with you i brought
my sister and my father all right they
they heard me all year long biggest
cheerleaders in your life huh non-stop
talking about your dad your dad's he's
over shaking his head he's proud of you
yeah very well
very cool yeah good stuff good stuff
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
i tell people definitely it's
consistency
discipline
and also just a belief in yourself
because there's going to be times when
it gets really really hard and you're
not going to really have anybody on your
side really pushing you because
everybody has their own agenda their own
things to do and so really a firm belief
and vision in yourself and your future
is what's going to get you through those
hard times yeah way to go isabella
you're a rock star you're a hero
very very proud of you what a lot of
transition there yes a lot of change a
lot of stuff going on a lot of stress
all during a stressful time pulled it
all off yeah you're an amazing young
woman very very well done
very well done good stuff all right
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
for you that is definitely the next
chapter in your story to
continue to change your entire legacy
now very well done and i copy the total
money makeover book you can pass that
along to someone when you're talking
about financial peace university like
you drug your 21 year old sister there a
few years ago so very cool stuff good
stuff all right it's isabella from los
angeles 34 000
paid off in 12 months making 56 to 60.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
3 2 1. i'm debt free
[Music]
yeah
this is how it's done right here
so i have a prediction for you all right
she's going to make over 100 in the real
estate business her first year no yes
for sure she's going to double her
income yeah she's going to crush it and
zoom through the baby steps because of
it just boom boom boom boom boom ticking
them off just crushing him yeah she's
she got two out of the way she's relaxed
she's not afraid of hard work no she's
got a a poise yes and a way she carries
herself she's going to do very very well
in the real estate business yeah it's
going to work out very well and but
there's something interesting there's a
tie
there always has been between what you
do and what we what i do the career and
the money yeah right that that the the
money being right frees you up to do the
career the career being right making a
lot of money frees you up to go win with
your money that's right they they bounce
back and forth between so ping pong and
it works together that's it she did it
so well it's the left right combination
and i just want to tell you
your mama is so proud i know your dad
and your sister are proud but so is your
mama amen incredible fortitude
proud of man amen
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day john 14 27
peace i leave with you my peace i give
to you
i do not give to you as the world gives
do not let your hearts be troubled
and do not be afraid
rosa parks said i have learned over the
years that when one's mind is made up
this diminishes fear
very true
laney is with us laney is in what in the
world did i do there
hello there's laney hey lainey welcome
to the ramsey show how can ken and i
help
hi gabe hi ken bear with me i have a lot
of moving pieces um i'm an occupational
therapist i work in the hospital i also
have a part-time job and outpatient i'm
on baby step two
i'm getting married in august
and i'm just very burned out on the
hospital i'm living in asheville
my lease ends in november
and the plan was was for my fiance to
get a job first and i kind of go from
there because my job's more flexible um
but i got anxious found a job that
offered the job and it's gonna be an
eight thousand dollar pay raise
i'm just
now i'm having second
thoughts on
am i cornering my fiance into a place or
should i
where is the job
and where's the job greenville south
carolina okay so you would be moving
and your your lease is up in november
and you're getting married to win again
august august okay and so had you guys
already decided on greenville south
carolina or this is where the job has
come up and now he's got to decide or
you have to decide if that's where we
want to go help me understand
this is where the job came up so we have
not decided on a location at all okay so
if you're having second thoughts what
are his thoughts i'm sure i'm assuming
since you mentioned him and cornering
him have you guys discussed this and
what's his take
yeah um he
isn't super decisive about it he likes
the area but
he does feel like
he wishes that he could find a job first
because
i could essentially go anywhere where
his
it might be harder for him to find a job
okay so you called us which way were you
leaning at the start of this call
oh i'm really really conflicted i
i'm really worried that i am making a
rash decision like to jump on this job
because i'm so burned out at the
hospital okay and this job would start
in september so it's kind of like a
really quick easy out for me yeah i
think you have to listen to that uh here
but i want to dive in here
tell me about the parts that are causing
you to feel burned out and another way
of asking this is what would you remove
if you had a magic wand what would you
pull away from what you're doing right
now that's sucking your soul out
well so the biggest piece is
the salary is not what i expected when i
got the student loans that i did okay
for an occupational therapist okay if
i'm working
that doesn't cause you to burn out
that's not work related that's emotion
attached to the reality that a lot of
people are facing when they get these
expensive degrees that they take loans
out and they go wait a second i thought
i was gonna make more i'm asking you do
is there type is there types of things
you're doing that are burning you out
or is it just the emotional running to
run away from this particular hospital
why why what's sucking the life
so
it has been
so many staff cuts we're super we've
been super overworked okay so you're
overwhelmed which is which i've i've
written about this i've got an article
on this at kencoleman.com it's one of
the five causes of what i call build up
on the heart see burnout is the symptom
if i go to the doctor today laney with a
knee uh with knee pain i'm not going
i've got knee pain i want to know what's
causing the pain and and so being
overwhelmed drinking from a fire hydrant
is is what you're identifying here so
let me simplify this if we removed all
of the stuff that's causing all this the
stress and just feeling overwhelmed and
i put you in a different place doing
occupational therapy would you be
happy in your work
yeah i think so i i am made to be an
occupational therapist
hold on pause that's huge
that's what you have to realize you were
made to be an occupational therapist so
we're doing
the right thing in the wrong place we
have a little quiz at dave well she
knows that she's wanting to leave i know
but that's why my dad got inside coleman
she already told you that no but but she
needs to hear that because she was gonna
take another job just as an occupational
therapist no she was gonna take it she
was gonna she was rushing into something
as opposed to saying i need to stay in
occupational therapy she was she was
going to stay in occupational therapy
yeah so the other job is home health
it's not occupational therapy it's still
it's an occupational therapist i thought
you were staying you're staying in the
career but i thought i heard her say it
was a little bit different than what
she's doing now did i misunderstand that
let me back up a second on something
that's bothering me in this whole thing
when are you getting married again
august okay this is this is july
so when is it your fiance is gonna go
get a freaking job
my thoughts exactly
yeah i think he needs to get all painter
get off the ladder here
yeah
but you should not take the job in
greenville i don't think that's good for
the relationship no i think but i think
he's got about 30 days
or no no whining
like by the time you get married he
should have his job lined up in the city
and then you go over there and get you
an occupational therapy job in that city
and you're still going to be in there by
september yes
and the point but him sitting around on
his butt till christmas not figuring
this out is not one of the options on
the table right
you could tell him i said that
or are you waiting on him like why do
you have to why does he have to go
you're not forcing him he does need to
get his button gear
mm-hmm but here's the point i'm trying
to make laney
dave's having fun with me i get it
here's the point
you're not burned out from being an
occupational therapist you're just
burned out in the current environment
don't mistake that that's all stay with
occupational therapy yeah you're doing
the right thing but get out of that
environment i agree and i'm i'm with you
on this lanny i think you can land that
pretty easily
and you just have to be selective about
the environment wherever he wants but he
loses his option on cities if he doesn't
take the option
by the wedding
okay do you think i'd give him
30 days he gets to he gets until then to
choose cities and choose his little
career thing otherwise he'd be following
you
yeah
yeah and i don't want that i
i want him to grow in his career i do
too but that means he has to actually go
do it he has to get on the ladder before
he can climb
yeah what's he do what's his field
he's a supervisor in commercial
landscaping
well you can do that anywhere
yeah i've never heard of a supervisor in
landscaping deciding which city wants to
go to i mean you guys collectively say
that this is where we want to live we he
can go do that anywhere as well and you
can go do occupational therapy anywhere
so let's let's have a meeting tomorrow
night decide where we want to live
and then let's go get a couple jobs
there before the wedding yeah and then
you can quit your job and you'll be out
of that hospital by september and you go
to occupational therapy and he goes dude
goes and does commercial landscaping i
mean any major metro area has got
commercial landscaping believe me
anybody's like i got office buildings
and apartments and so forth that's just
that's the deal
um so i mean there's 73 000 of them
within a two mile radius of this place
they're over here every day bothering us
so um i know that you know it's just
possible right i mean can you yeah they
want to get this job right this this
building yeah there's a lot of
landscaping to do around here yeah so
you're telling me you're not a fan of
the leaf blower right outside of the
conference rooms
is that what i'm hearing
i don't know it was like a thing at the
old office every time we would start a
meeting some guy would go by with a leaf
blower about the time we're in the room
full on staff meeting yeah
so yeah the great news is you can land
both of these jobs anywhere you guys
want to do laney this is about you all
getting aligned on your timing and your
motivation and ambition
and both of you being on the same page
you're more driven to get out of that
hospital and he's not driven enough i'm
kicking him in the butt in this call
because he's leaving you on hold
and you on hold is driving you bananas
and you're screaming burn out burn out
burnout and there's really no burnout
because you're gone by september
you can survive until september i
promise yeah so you got this kid
congratulations on your marriage it's
gonna be awesome you're gonna have a
great new city picked out by the end of
the week
awesome it's gonna be incredible ken
good job thank you for having me fun
stuff good job in the booth guys i'm
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country to find a
station near you head to thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you